[Musique]
il est l'heure il c'est le moment
d'accueillir celle qui va donner le coup
d'envoi
le coup d'envoi de cette onzième saison
elle est là elle vient d'arriver on me
le dire priorité au direct et qui elle
est là ce soir expressément pour nous
elle est à paris pour quelques jours on
a vu sur les réseaux sociaux
son nouveau petit copain elle est avec
nous ce soir
tout à l'heure du rail gérard depardieu
à vous dire voilà qui sera là hélas non
on avait une soeur kylie jenner avec
nous jugera bull minutes pour donner le
coup d'envoi
voilà on rêve alors elle va évacuer 4e
minute a pas donné le coup d'envoi de la
11e saison est malade est avec nous
c'est qu'ils ont fait avant mais sauf
qu'elles font pas de la bretagne
[Applaudissements]
c'est certainement la plus grande star
mondiale
elle nous fait l'honneur d'être avec
nous ce soir kylie jenner pour donner le
coup d'envoi de cette onzième saison d'à
voulu taper très fort gérard depardieu
le patron le taulier donc pour premier
habité touche pas à mon poste et kylie
jenner qui étaient avec nous on va aller
la chercher
kylie qui va donner le coup d'envoi de
la 11e saison messieurs on va pas la
faire attendre plus longtemps
merci applaudissements pour elle elle
est là ce soir car yves et chaleur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'oubli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si c'est moi c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
m'avait vendu c'est kylie bouder ça on a
en galère de budget pour qu'on vous
reconnaisse gré merci j'avais un texte
mais il me fait rigoler lui non mais je
suis très content d'être ici donc la
kalina vrai pour des raisons budgétaires
oui elle peut pas venir oui mais voilà
on a pris un cas évident qu'ils disent
qu'ils adhèrent je voulais absolument
qu'il soit avec nous pour cette première
voilà qui passe une tête parce que c
était je suis pas plus belle que kylie
moi ça a été une des grandes stars pour
nous l'année dernière il a fait une
année exceptionnelle il sera avec moi
dans la grande rigueur la grosse
rigolade bien entendu et vous derrière
son livre qui sort il va faire
l'émission avec moi cette semaine je
crois il est calé oui on à vannes et est
officiellement comme en foot c'est que
je t'aime mais je crois qu'on a mais
j'ai quand même jetés ramener mieux que
kylie c'est vrai non mais là c'est pas
une blague
alors il ya gérard depardieu qui verra
le vrai tout à l'heure ça oui c'est vrai
si un enfant j'ai envie de m'imposer
j'ai un message de quelqu'un qu'on adore
tous et c'est encore mieux que kylie
alors je vous laisse le découvrir c'est
parti enfin peut-être aller à la classe
[Applaudissements]